So in my city of Athens, Greece,
like in many cities around the world,
a lot of people thought
that climate change
is something happening far away.
Until ash started falling from the sky
and temperatures neared
45 degrees Celsius
in the summer of 2021,
and they stayed above 40 degrees
for several days.
The asphalt sizzled and huge wildfires
burned the forests around the city
and people died.
The last decade has been the hottest
ever recorded in our history.
Paradoxically, even though we've been
talking about global warming for decades,
we haven't been talking
about extreme heat,
especially in urban environments.
Extreme heat is the deadliest
of all extreme weather phenomena.
Very few of us know this.
We overlook extreme heat
because heat doesn't come
with the drama of roofs sent flying
and streets turned into rivers.
Heat destroys quietly.
Yet there is little escape from heat.
These are temperatures our bodies
are not made for and cannot adapt to.
These are temperatures our cities
and our infrastructure is not made for.
The structures of our cities
and the surfaces absorb heat
and store it and radiate it at night.
Cars and air conditioning add more
to the urban environment.
And this is a deadly mix.
This is what we call
the urban heat island.
The list of health effects from heat
and from heat waves is long,
and it includes significant
mental problems,
mental health problems.
It also,
heat creates fatigue and loss of sleep,
which in turn increases workplace injuries
as well as significant
losses of productivity.
Heat waves also, we know,
that they increase
violence in communities,
we have correlated it to increased
and also they lower the ability
of children to learn.
And in the cities,
not everybody, of course,
is affected equally.
The poor, especially the energy-poor
and the housing-poor are most vulnerable
as well as people
with pre-existing conditions,
people above 60 years old,
pregnant women, young children
and people that have manual labor jobs.
Also, we know that heat
has been baking farmers' crops,
reducing yields,
inhibiting pollination,
and more and more farm workers
are going to work before daybreak
or farming in the night,
harvesting in the night.
It's just getting too darn hot.
The great infrastructures
that we have built
with ingenuity and effort
during the last two centuries,
the dams, the waterways,
the highways, the railways,
they have been carefully engineered
for a climate that no longer exists.
What can we do?
I will talk about cities
because that's my territory.
As chief heat officer of Athens,
I think of all possible efforts
in three general categories.
Awareness,
preparedness and redesign.
Awareness means
that we recognize the threat.
It's hard sometimes to persuade people,
especially in hot climates,
to take heat exposure seriously.
So this year, together with
the Arsht-Rockefeller Resilience Center,
we are going to pilot,
for the first time this summer,
four cities in the US and Athens,
we're going to pilot
a new methodology for naming
and categorizing heat waves
like we do hurricanes.
So consider this.
When there is a category 4 hurricane,
you don't expect the pizza delivery person
to bring a pizza to your house,
nor do you expect, like, people to keep
working in a construction site.
However, we don't have
such considerations or policies
in relation to a category 4 heat wave
because there is no category
4 heat waves.
We don’t have metrics,
and we don’t have categories.
And I think that this will be
a real game changer.
So this is just one thing,
but I think this is important.
So awareness leads to preparedness,
and preparedness means
that you are kind of, ready
to basically, when the event happens,
to protect the most vulnerable.
And there's a whole slew of actions
that cities are doing
all around the world,
short-term things, to protect people
during the heat waves.
For example, in Athens,
we have created a smartphone app
that gives you personalized
and real-time risk assessment
and gives you, on a map,
risk assessments in relation to heat,
and gives you on a map
where you can go to get cover,
where are the cool spaces,
the nearest cool spaces.
New York has created
this great buddy system
where people in the neighborhood
keep on checking during heat waves
on people that are vulnerable
in the neighborhood.
They also gave,
I think a couple of years ago,
74,000 units of air conditioning
for low-income seniors.
Sydney does this great thing,
which is that they divert energy
from the industrial sector
to residential districts
to avoid blackouts
during heat waves.
So these are some
short-term things that we can do
and we've been doing.
But the real task at hand
is redesigning our cities
to make our cities cooler
and thinking beyond air conditioning.
So before we started designing
our buildings and our cities
and cooling them and heating them
with fossil fuels,
architecture had incorporated
centuries-long wisdom
for design solutions and materials
that were fine-tuned
to the local climate conditions.
So thick walls with tiny openings
or well-placed windows
high up in the building
that kind of move air
from the bottom up and out
or outside shutters.
Shady and verdant internal
courtyards with fountains
or outside walls
that are whitewashed every spring
to reflect the hot summer heat,
the heat of the hot summers.
So compare these to our concrete,
steel and glass buildings
that are air conditioned
and that have sealed windows
that basically make our cities
into heat traps
compounding instead
of solving the problem.
So, what we really need to do
is we need to radically
rethink and redesign
our urban environments
away from the logic of modernity,
away from the logic of carbon modernity.
Carbon is there from the get go,
from the materials that we use
for the types of construction,
from the way we use the buildings,
we heat and cool them,
the way we eat, the way we consume,
the way we move around
in our urban environments.
So we need to redesign our cities
beyond energy efficiency
and cutting carbon emissions.
We need an urban design revolution,
a total paradigm shift
that probably needs
to be led not by architects anymore,
but landscape architects
that know more
about thermodynamics and soil
and the importance
of soils for biodiversity
and all these things that can really
bring about a real paradigm shift,
a revolution in design,
a new type of urbanity
that actually is a different
metabolic animal.
Our cities of the future will be
different metabolic systems.
And we don't really know yet
what this is going to look like,
but I think it’s going to be great,
and it’s just the beginning.
But what we do know is that we really,
really urgently need to build resilience
to our current climate conditions
at urban scale.
There are materials
and technologies that are currently
being developed that will help,
but the main thing, the first and foremost
and most important thing
for bringing down heat in cities
is bringing nature into the urban fabric.
And this means a radical increase
of trees, of tree coverage,
of biodiversity and of water
in the surfaces of our cities
so that we can bring down the heat.
(Applause)
So this is the time, this is the decade,
and this means that cities
have to really think
the interconnections and interdependencies
between different urban systems,
and they have to think
of resources very carefully
and build backup systems
and redundancies,
flexibility and diversity.
And think about sustainability and equity,
because this is how we build
resilience in our cities.
And cities are already doing it
and they’re changing.
And we're very much learning
from each other
because for the first time,
the last few decades,
cities belong in powerful urban networks
so we're kind of talking with each other
and learning from each other.
Networks like Resilient Cities Network
and C40 are really supporting cities.
And I'm going to give you a finish
by giving you a few examples
of what cities have done,
and of course, I'm going
to start from Athens.
So in Athens, we have
this incredible Roman aqueduct,
a brilliant, ancient masterpiece
of design and engineering
that runs for 20 kilometers
underground, totally invisible,
and still today moves
enormous amounts of water
from the hills outside of Athens
to the center of Athens.
The water is great, too,
it's perfect for irrigation,
you don't need to do anything to it.
And for decades now,
we've been just throwing it
into the sewage and then to the sea.
So now this urban aqueduct,
this ancient monument,
is going to be used to build
resilience and lower heat
by supporting urban nature
for the modern city of Athens.
Another great example
is Medellín, in Colombia.
Medellín, they created 36 green corridors,
a dense network of trees and flower beds
that has lowered temperatures
four degrees Celsius in the city,
and it does a lot of other things,
ecosystemic services,
like captures pollution
and noise pollution and water
and soil erosion.
So all these things have
really important ecosystemic services.
You probably know,
Seoul in South Korea,
they dismantled a highway
that was ten lanes long
and it had four lanes on top expressway,
to restore a stream underneath
and [they] created this blue corridor
and green corridor, 3.6 miles long,
a continuous space for wildlife
and people to walk and bicycle,
that not only lowers temperatures,
they've measured that it goes
up to 5.9 degrees Celsius,
that it lowers temperatures in that area,
But also it protects
the city from flooding.
And, of course, it attracts
thousands of visitors every day,
has created a lot of jobs
and has supported business development
more than any other part of Seoul.
Paris is using the water of the Seine
to give free cooling to buildings
around the river.
And finally, I'll finish
with Melbourne in Australia
because they have created
an incredible strategy
that's called Nature in the City Strategy,
where they've analyzed and think
how to bring together
all of the levels of the ecosystem
from the soil and the fungi underneath
to the plants and the animals
and the birds and the insects
and the frogs
and put into place all these actions
that will ensure
that the urban environment,
that their kids will grow up,
will be richer and much healthier.
So, what keeps me
really excited about this work,
working to help cities cool down
and work against climate change,
is also that I feel
that I'm really helping
create much more
wonderful cities to live in.
So just think about this,
cranking up the air conditioning
is just not going to cut it.
Thank you.
(Applause)